just to clarify the discussion and
review a little bit of really the last
six videos the Geithner plan Geithner
consists of two plans there's a legacy
loans plan legacy loans and then there's
the legacy Securities and I talked about
this in the last video legacy securities
and what immediately is I would say at
best suspicious is that what everyone
can participate in is the legacy loans
program but this isn't really the crux
of the issue that everyone's been
talking about in the financial crisis
the whole issue of under non liquid
markets and the collateralized debt
obligations and the difference between
the bid and the acts ask price that's
occurring here in the legacy securities
program and they've limited this to
essentially only five players five
players and they've made the bar so high
namely that you have to have greater
than 10 billion dollars in in legacy
secure in these types of what they call
eligible securities which means these
toxic assets eligible securities so
first of all there aren't that many fund
complexes that even manage 10 billion
total much less that already owned ten
billion dollars in eligible security is
not i don't know if that's ten billion
dollars of face value or market value
i'm assuming face value because arguably
we don't know what the market value is
but this is a very small group of people
it's arguably not much more than five
players so even though the the Treasury
is making it look like they don't know
who these five people are going to be
and they're going to have some type of
competitive process we can rest assured
that they've already talked to these
five players they know exactly who these
five people are they know that not that
many people can even compete to be one
of the five players and they wouldn't
even announce the number five or that
there would be five players if they
already didn't have the buy-in from
these five guys and what makes the
legacy securities you know not besides
the fact that it's being limited to a
small pool of people who could easily
collude with each other and the Treasury
and the banks in some way what makes
this especially disturbing is that the
legacy security program actually allows
even more leverage or even a better
option a put option than what's offered
in the legacy loans program
and just kind of review instead of ifs
let's say someone thought that a fair
value of a security was thirty dollars
where's thirty dollars in that reality
and this is a pure review of the last
video but I think it's worth mentioning
because I think I might have done it a
little bit too fast at the end of the
video the payoff for your security would
look like this so let's say that the
x-axis is the value value of security
and then this is the value of your
investment well in this reality you're
your entire investment is the security
so the payoff is just going to be a line
that looks like this it's just going to
look like that so let's say you paid
this is the amount that you paid you
paid thirty dollars from the get-go so
the security ends up being worth forty
dollars right here then the value of
your investment is forty dollars and you
would have made this difference you
would have made the ten dollars likewise
if the security ends up being worth
twenty dollars that's right here this is
the value of the security then your
investment is worth twenty dollars and
you'll take this $10 hit this is kind of
the plain vanilla scenario before the
Geithner situation what we explained in
the last video is instead of doing this
if you are one of the lucky five players
to participate in the legacy securities
program what instead of putting thirty
dollars in you could put 225 in to one
of these funds to 25 from you the
Treasury puts in another 225 225 this is
from the Treasury this is from Pym rock
pim rock one of the five players and
then the extra leverage here is that the
Treasury will then give up to another
hundred percent loan on top of this so
this is 450 so the Treasury will get
will then give all the loans in yellow
will give another 450 loan here they say
fifty to one hundred percent but it's at
the treasures discretion we're really
just trying to figure out how much the
taxpayer can get hosed so let's say it's
one hundred percent and then you can
leverage and then this capital right
here can then part
dissipate in the legacy towel program
which allows them to buy these legacy
toxic assets and so then they go to the
Fed and they say okay fed give us a loan
the Fed can then give them a loan for
$51 right get that 621 leverage and my
suspicion is that they're going to allow
more than 61 levers they're just using
61 as the example because it is at the
discretion of the Fed the Fed just talks
about haircuts haircut is essentially
just how much leverage if I if they take
a ten percent haircut on the collateral
that means that they're allowing 10 to 1
leverage but anyway this is the loan
from the Fed $51 is the example I did
last time and then you have sixty
dollars of buying power sixty dollars of
buying power which you could then
instead of buying one security you could
then by to securities and explain it in
the last video the whole reason why I
even did this is because we're splitting
the equity with the Treasury so if we
want the same upside we have to buy
twice as many securities but in this
reality now if if the value of the
security ends up being worth forty
dollars then each of these are worth
forty the total value of all of this is
worth 80 right you pay off these loans
right so you have eighty dollars minus
what 55 50-55 50 that's 2450 2450 and
then let me see that I do that math
right 4-4 50 so that's fifty five fifty
right there's 2450 and then that 2450 is
essentially what represents the the
equity capital that's what after the
assets minus all of your liabilities and
then this is split between you and the
Treasuries so you get half of that so
it's 1250 the value of your investment
is 1250 so you just made ten dollars
right because your initial investment
was only 225 and to make it look right
on this diagram let's say you started
with a 30 with thirty dollars instead of
putting it all in the security what you
do is you put 225 here and then you put
2775 aside in some super safe situation
and if you do that in this reality if
the security is worth forty dollars the
value of your investment
is worth forty dollars right because
this 225 is now worth 12 25 with 12 25
and then you have the 2775 so then that
gets you to forty dollars if it's worth
if it's thirty dollars you're still kind
of on this line but then if this value
here drops below 2775 you're okay you
get wiped out here but you still have
all this cash sitting on the side so the
payoff in the legacy securities program
looks like this and this is a complete
review and maybe I didn't have to review
this much in this video the payoff looks
like this and so this investment that
we've structured through the legacy
securities program is the exact same
thing as if I had bought the security
and then also had a put option a put
option gives you the right to sell at a
certain price so a put option at a 2775
strike price and so what the government
is essentially giving is this for free
and you know maybe I'll pay a little bit
more for it because I'm getting this
option for free and in the last video we
use an option price calculator to try to
put a value on this we said wow this
could be as much as this could be
twenty-four twenty-five dollars of value
depending on your assumptions and so now
a rational investor who was willing to
pay 30 might be willing to pay as much
as 24 25 dollars and that by itself
could close this bid-ask gap that
everyone's talked about where the banks
won't sell for less than sixty dollars
that's the offer price well no one while
the markets not willing to pay for 30
but there's something else going on here
and this goes back to the notion that
there's only five players there's only
five players and they all have ten
billion dollars already invested in
these markets and frankly they have ten
billion dollars already of these legacy
securities and the rest of their assets
are bonds many of them which are going
to be loans to financial intermediaries
to banks to other people that
essentially are intertwined with this
whole mess so if you view it that way
just going back to the Geithner to video
the Geithner to video was a very almost
naive analysis of how a bank could self
deal or banks incentive to overpay for
these things
but what you realize is if you're one of
these if you're one of these five
players right here you have just a
strong of an incentive to use the
government's money to overpay for these
assets right if my balance sheet if I'm
Pym rock and that's this is my these are
my assets assets and I don't know how
they're how they capitalize their
situation I assume most of it is uh I
assume most of their capital comes from
just direct investments from people but
maybe they leveraged ism so let me let
me give you the benefit that's it's all
equity right if you look at PIM rocks
holdings some fictional large bond
company sure maybe 10 billion are these
toxic assets right 10 billion but guess
what they have a ton of other loans
let's say that they have a 5 billion
dollar loan let me say for the sake of
argument let's say they have a 10
billion dollar loan to I don't know
Citibank and let me draw a city bank's
balance sheet now so let's say Citibank
and you can play with the numbers but I
just want to really illustrate what the
point of why pim rock would want to
overpay for city bank's assets so let me
draw their liability side of their
balance sheet Citibank alright so City
Bank has some toxic assets right here
who carry out maybe I'll describe some
value to this is their equity this is
citibanks equity and they have a loan
from pit rock right PIM rock owns 10
billion dollars of citibank bonds and
they're probably not the only person we
could talk about that situation although
the five people participating this
program probably do represent a large
chunk of the bonds that the bank's
trying to offload the assets have out
there and frankly the other bonds that
they've borrowed from are from banks
that therefore then issued more bonds to
these guys so these guys really are the
linchpin of the system but just to make
the the diagram clear this is so City
Bank has a 10 billion dollar
loan from PIM rock and this is toxic
right here now if we just force the
market to happen citibank's not going to
get this amount for it they're only
going to get this amount right so this
is what city bank's balance sheet would
look like this is before the Geithner
plan city bank's balance sheet those
toxic assets would get disposed the
balance sheet would shrink to that but
their liabilities are larger right Cindy
banks liabilities would look like that
and obviously the equity is what what is
whatever occurs after you subtract out
the live leads from the assets but you
have negative equity here so the
stockholders get wiped out in that
scenario but even these bond holder
right here this bond holder in this case
PIM rock gets impaired right the value
of the security is them would would you
know get a haircut of some it would be
well depending on how you want to talk
about it but if in a bankruptcy
situation this would be called the
fulcrum security this is the security
where the vought the real enterprise of
the value of the real enterprise value
of the company sits so if you're if
you're pim rock right here if you
overpay if you use some of your extra
capital and actually is not even extra
capital you're going to start a new fund
partnering with the Treasury but if that
new fund right here uses their app money
to overpay for these toxic assets right
instead of paying only this amount for
them they overpay this amount and
they're doing it remember primarily with
government money and they're allowing
you to lever up 2532 one where the
government is taking really ninety
ninety-five percent of the hit so you
use the government money to overpay
these things you aren't the bank but
that makes these bonds good now all of a
sudden these other assets that you own
that were loans to other banks now they
become good now that you know Citibank
might have had other loans to other
banks right but those other banks might
have borrowed from PIM rock so when you
make their loans good then you make this
Bank less likely default and so the
entire bond portfolio especially the
part that's exposed to the financial
sector then becomes worth a lot more so
on a lot of levels one
you're giving them this huge put option
which gives this huge incentive to
overpay for the stock where for the
Securities you're making it very closed
and you essentially are pre picking who
gets to participate and that makes it
very easy to collude and your by making
the the people who play the people who
already participated in the mess by all
these people are already kind of
knee-deep in it because they already
have 10 billion of exposure you're
giving them a huge incentive to use
taxpayer money to essentially overpay
for the legacy Securities and the net
effect of all of this is is that you
know these guys are going to make out
pretty well the banks are going to make
out super well because the taxpayer is
essentially issuing free put options and
providing a huge incentive to overpay
for these assets and obviously you know
bill growth Bill Gross he Bill Gross
said that there's you know it's kind of
a win-win-win for the investors for the
banks and the taxpayers but it's very
clear from this situation that it's it's
a big zero for the taxpayers and they
really are just further subsidizing the
same people on a massive scale I mean
we're talking about close to a trillion
dollars and I wouldn't be surprised if
we exceed a trillion dollars before all
of this is done to the very same people
who essentially caused this disaster so
it's like if we started selling arms to
al-qaeda anyway see in the next video